Limit
[music]
It was a few minutes new
His alter ego may have been the day before It's an illusion
Is
it
different from the ordinary reality that can't be solved?
I can never
get out of this fog in the
woods You can never make me disappear
This fog is transferring my illusions
[music] I'm thirsty [music]
That's what
Why are we related
This infinite corridor isn't just about grass and trees
, it's taking away your body's moisture too, so it's not
Bill
What
the heck?
Either dry up or die The
air is fine I'll
come back to explain the cheap food
Smooth even without throwing that blade in illusion It's
beautiful
I have to
find out how I did
it.